I think I I don't have very much
discussion over whatever you said is I'm
completely disagree when you said men
are more clever than women because I'm
in CL clinical field as well okay so I'm
working in the hospital as well and IQ
we have seven types at least seven types
I IQ that um you know have recognize we
have a sport IQ have a math IQ have a
other you can't say generalize that
women are less um clever how many
Discovery has a women how many Discovery
how many Discovery has a women okay do
you want how many Theory have a how many
philosophy has a women how many artist
has a women no open Google no this is
billionaires let's talk about the
billionaires the richest women
billionaires divorce that's the funniest
thing the most successful women got
their money why divor why divorce has
relationship with the IQ
I'm but I'm asking about outcom so the
women with the most money how did they
get there was it was it through being so
smart and competent or was was let's
let's let's let's think about I'm
thinking about our female billionaires
one has a sex tape one sells makeup and
the other's got their money through
divorce I'm ex model and I work in
healthcare and I'm ex model you're
you're a model I'm a model okay and you
work in healthcare and I work in
healthcare yes okay and I have a black
belt in karate and I bet I bet you he
could still you say and if you say that
womens are not
clever no no she said she said the men
are more clever okay now I'm completely
disagree we can't say who is where we
have to say I think we can look at the
outcome so we can see who who is not an
outcome is which category you know the
men can't be a better Runner if the if
they run with women because they have
testosterone they have a bigger muscles
okay not because they are more clever
they I you know the sport IQ then higher
but you can compare this lady with this
lady okay this men with comparing the
men you said once one time you said men
are different with women the brain is
different their size is different the
home and then you compare the IQ
together is absolutely wrong exactly
Absol
I'm I'm looking I'm looking at out I'm
looking at I'm looking at what well I
don't not beautiful I'm not talking
about beauty no you said Beauty I said
we monetize I I said okay let's talk
about value added to society what makes
Society
run no no wait wait wait wait wait let
me let me let me I need you remember
remember mute your mic again all right
this is your final warning one more time
you're going to go okay ladies I don't
think to me like that I'm sorry okay
thank you is very important all right
thank you all right all right wait what
did you say it respect your guest okay
actually you can go now thank you
goodbye yeah goodbye um Security will
escort you out wow yeah that's pretty
yeah I've warned you like three times to
what to stop overt talking me we read
you the rules at the beginning of the
show it's all right go ahead everyone
talking with each other no all right and
now you're going to keep talking back
goodbye goodbye go please wow please
exclude my conversation everything from
this video no it's live so I'll see
you oh my gosh it's very impolite of you
you didn't invite me to keep me out I
didn't want to yeah but I'm calling the
people to invite me I work since 8
morning 7 p.m. in the hospital I put
there for okay I have 8 years old
waiting for me all right and you ask me
to kick out it's very disrespectful I
mean if you knew all that you could have
just followed the rules though I
I because she wanted you over and over
again to stop over talking and even
while you were doing it just now she
still told you okay stop stop stop but
you just didn't y y'all see how y'all
see
how y'all see how her emotions just took
over though right it's just a clear
example of how everything she was saying
was [__] she doesn't like it people
put a lot
of all right it's a clear it's a clear
example can you take her out please
thank you
just a
minute no no she doesn't no go take out
take your sh out no no that's not your
show no no no I'm I'm not interested no
no please leave please leave can you
just leave cuz you have it's not worth
it leave this is this is the problem
asked to leave just leave
please no take her out take her out can
I just say I don't take her get out get
out on babe don't worry about it it's
just a it's just a show it's just a show
it's just a
show it's just a show I respect you but
it I just just sit down and have a good
show I don't want you to leave no no
goodbye goodbye no she's go just please
be respectful that's all she
said okay yeah just watch out bro watch
watch out bro she's a black belt in
karate
oh gosh so crazy she's a black Bo in
karate saying watch out
Chief are you going to are you going to
publish this end of this
conversation yes goodbye goodbye good
bye I don't remember what we're talking
about um sorry can I just go to yeah I
don't care go
ahead can I speak so you said you're a
psychologist yeah yeah so you think why
do you think why do you think why do you
think why do you think men are more
clever what's the psychology behind that
you know it's about to understand who
you are and which energy you have more
female or male of course exist now a lot
of male women where are you where are
you from where's from oh I I have a long
story I born in Russia after I live many
many years in Bulgaria I I had to have
been Eastern it has to be EAS yeah
what's the meaning of
prejudice ask yourself that no because
no don't come here cuz I'm cond it
that's extremely condesending it is it
is it is you know come on come on come
on you're being very condesending you're
being very very everything you said I'm
actually not being condent I'm trying to
be very polite you are everything you
move
on you you what and I told you I gave
you examples you Haven given us the
right
have there so many different examples
of literally against women you could you
could have Googled in the bathroom you
so much I literally told it doesn't
matter P at this I'm saying when people
when it's talk about peace you don't TR
I feel like you guys you guys don't try
and have a conversation you guys try to
draw out people you draw out people and
that's the reason why people get we're
not discussion you know do you do you do
you know what's interesting you
yelling
she yells over
everybody okay okay she yells over
everybody and cries about dis okay that
is go go after you
blame give a [__] what I come to the
show they ask you you me to come to the
show you me to
come I didn't I actually I'm going to be
honest I don't invite anybody my
recruiters what's the definition of
prejudice what's the definition of
prejudice you get married first
oh wow the baby the baby mother divorce
is reling about marri you're if you're
going to do it to me I'll do B she's
overweight it's like the fat baby mom is
going to talk to me about being married
get out of here get out of you started
you start it ma'am yep yep goodbye I'll
see you okay then please leave just what
what a wow wow wow yeah wow yeah
yeah yeah I'm very I'm very
unhappy wow wow
this this is so funny ma'am ma'am ma'am
ma'am ma'am please can I say something
if you want women to look good ma'am
ma'am ma'am if you want women to look
good please please just stop
talking arguing yeah I did break up
because of my daughter because I didn't
want her to see the arguments but P just
H okay so let's take you're take that's
more of a traditional thing to stay
together for the S
of but
all go she's got to go she's too drunk
she's got to go no I'm not drunk you
told her about to
drunk I didn't
say she's going to go I didn't say that
don't went for the head
she's Health if you put your hands
please one moment put your hands on me
I'm saying to
[Music]
you want phone I want
phone we'll get your
phone y what's going on didn't do
anything to you what's going on get your
hands off me what's going on get your
hands off me now get your [__] hands
on me no one's never going to watch this
podcast my God get l
boy and Juice
boy Sam it's okay just come
out I'm PR you don't you can't go down
the stairs that's not your flat you put
your hands on me I'm getting the police
now one time no you're being prosecuted
right
now right now can't tell me what I'm
doing I want my
stuff what I'm doing
all right listen what no no I'm calling
Polie they can see they can see this
podcast now I've been abused by you see
it move for me if you don't move me I'm
going to show move
meus
me hello putting his hands on me this
way can I have the pleas pleas I've been
assaulted no I've been assaulted no I've
been assaulted get off me stay away from
me certain tone I just said to her calm
down yeah you said it straight still I
heard that and then she tried it and I
would I'm not upset happen kissing that
and then yeah but and then she goes I
know you're the real one I know you're
the real one yeah she's been trying to
Rattle people's CES from the start you
know I to let her know I ain't that guy
you know just can't be bothered anymore
okay all right I think the show starts
now let's go let's go let's have fun we
you can finally get the answers to what
people give up for social media or for
their
relationship patience is a virtue by the
way oh Lord you got a dangerous smile
you got to stop smiling over
here smile over here bit shiny but yeah
I like it I'm hating the camera why I
don't I need a hat man look at my
forehead
listening no you do it right brother
yeah ply Clips what's going on she's
still
security he's done nothing wrong he's
done what he's trying to do what's to do
she's not going to be coming back if she
comes back obviously you have the doors
soly you have the legal power to remove
someone from the building that is what
that's what you've done um we're going
to get rid of her a report will go say
this is happen come Clos comes back
rather than you get in a position where
you can get in trouble
just right enjo rest of your you might
have a girl come back to your yard at 2:
a.m. yeah and you know what you might
try to [__] her and she don't want to
[__] you then you know what you'll never
see her again where some people might
just wait chill get to know the girl and
in the future they still will [__] her
get what I'm saying what you mean if she
don't want to [__] [__] her again maybe
I'll say cool no problem darling that's
no problem you I'm never going to I'm
not going to force myself on to her are
you asking me a question if a girl comes
to your yard at 2: a.m. you're going to
do what what do you expect to do bro
exactly you have an expectation what do
you expect to you have an expectation 2.
it's 2 A.A this Isa what saying because
we live in reality come
on wait this is soit wait that's basic
wait this is your last warning this your
last warning it's so it's so so all
right go go bye thank you all all right
all right say no more of him oh finally
finally peacein [__] boy all right I'm
going to I'm going to read the super
chat um okay guys make sure you like the
video um and and ring the notification
Bell um Clint um Clint Taurus I'm
getting simp Vibes in the back Amina um
I am uh I am a Muslim girl um and my cue
is from the girls do you think you being
used by many men is something you can be
proud of because of how happy about it
and girl why do you have a Chris Christ
symbol on your neck if you don't follow
his
teachings what is he not
[Laughter]
leaving uh for the women on the panel
you have girlfriends right um how would
you feel if your perfect man had slept
with every one of your friends that's
how men feel um Brian men get out of
your feelings stop
interrupting uh Francisco men are scared
of losing their phone more than or women
are scared of losing their phone more
than their virginity YouTube is lied um
uh has me edited this message multiple
times for no reason um if she can have a
body count will uh she will not this
might be your platform but respect
people when they come okay goodbye go go
go okay
CU up in his faceing on hereo listen
mind your you know what on the rebound
on the rebound on the rebound bro on the
rebound disrespected care you
disrespected know who you're talking how
I disrespect be careful first you call
me bro and then you said I call everyone
bro I have a show here I call everyone
bro bro don't so that's why she's
angry you're angry cuz I called you bro
I called Auntie bro and she's right next
to me no Auntie hates it Auntie hates
it Auntie told you long time in here on
thecast but this in the streets as well
mind yourself mind yourself yeah you're
damn right you're damn right BR right
and I'm going to see how [__] out you
are disrespect cuz I call everyone bro
don't call me bro I don't know you so
that's all you have to
say to say you but that's what you have
to say you just embarrassing yourself
embarrassing you know something right
you know something right excuse me
excuse me excuse me what's your name
hello young lady what's your name t do
you know what I'm going to do for the
first time ever I'm going to [__]
follow you see you
later I asked to speak before him look
it look it look it look it you're your
issue your issue stop you're doing it
again okay
you talking to a
[__] don't me bro why
you because you're a mom that's why
you're a [__] M bro you're lucky I'll
smoke you myself
you you [__] you [__] little mug
wow yeah right wow what's your Instagram
right now let me look at get it I'm just
honey can can we wait can we put it on
the screen I want to I want to react to
it oh my
God I just want to see I just want to
see the type of stuff you post right the
thing hold on hold on hold on guys I am
on a journey of like becoming more
religious so I am going to Rebrand my
Instagram here we
go okay I like I like how you don't say
I'm going to get closer with God re
listen listen this Instagram this
Instagram is absolutely
Haram is I this is har no she's changed
she's changed now she's changed
accountability stage's here what's here
what's here I haven't changed right now
but I'm on the journey too I am actually
on the Journey of I'm just honey H BEC
more modest and more religious but it's
a journey it's not easy in society wait
what if I grew up back home in h honey
hold on hold hold
on okay thank you plot in the Instagram
I you put yourself into this let's
listen hold on you put yourself into
this why did I speak guys I got to talk
to trying to get the i m j u s t h a n i
h and then your honor the evidence I'd
like to present to the court is uh
picture number five from the top and
picture number one pretty pretty Haram
do you want toe pleas I don't this is
this is was this the typ stuff you were
you were
posting look at that picture in the
middle that's Haram right
there why you showing your backside to
the world yeah that's the that's thck
store you know what I think it is yeah
as far as Instagram goes that's that's
not crazy about it's t but it's still
Haram it's still to some degree okay
look it's Haram as in as in like okay
you can see a bit of legs you can see a
bit of hair but however even with that
most people would have been like oh my
God this is not even not
we in the westernized
society wait wait wait wa wait I'm just
going to do you see how your gut
reaction isn't to listen is to defend
yourself I reaction it isn't it isn't it
isn't like oh maybe it is a bit Haram I
could it's wait wait you're still wait
turn off her
mic which which is fine you know I mean
we all start somewhere I have I'm
battling myself you're you're doing it
again honey calm down you need drink
this is my life guys I battled this in
my head all the time you'll get over
this eventually yeah but it's like it's
like if that's your initial response
that's probably contributed something
cuz like do you think your exes could
have told you
something and that you didn't like
Strang in at us yeah like you would have
you would have just listened said wait
wait wait wait and you would have just
said okay if we asked your exes if we
called your ex no no I feel like I would
be definitely described as defensive I
have this thing I grew up with seven
siblings we was always cussing other
yeah but see this is this is what women
do too so you're still now you're saying
well it's how I grew up and so now it's
like it's not on you it's on someone
else no I've done I've done this stuff
before too it's okay but no it's
something that I can change but as far
as let's go back to my Instagram goes I
battled this with myself as well so I'm
like okay I do um I used to have way
more pictures and I archived and
everything and I'm literally like slowly
finding a way to you know become more
mod dressed become more I think it's a
perspective thing you know and and it's
not a bad B this all the time with
myself and that's I'm not saying that's
not a bad thing that's good but I'm just
saying when we look back at situations
if we're always blame like pointing the
finger we can't grow we can't get better
yeah listen let's ask the chat chat if
you think her Instagram is Haram push a
one if you think it's not push a two
right there first of all I'm Haram right
now for not wearing a head scar so let's
start there
like we're we're in we're in a Christian
Nation okay so like well I guess I guess
you're ble but we're chrisan yeah I
battle myself a lot more than other but
you know what I think it is though I
genuinely think here that the issue here
isn't necessarily intentional or
malicious I think it's just a
perspective thing in this generation I
don't feel like a lot of women learn how
men are like or how they think or like
what their desires are so so it's like
the way it can translate across is that
oh wait I see that men like big boobs so
that was clearly what they want or see
but if females actually sit down with
men and say what would you want from a
wife now you know from your Instagram
early on you can want 100% argue it's
not that deep you know you can argue on
one side of the coin but on the flip
side of the coin you can also argue wait
the action she's faced away from the
screen got her bottom to the screen the
intention let's say that you don't it
doesn't matter what she's wearing let's
say the intention alone how could people
perceive it could we perceive it as
that's a woman that's got a husband and
that's a woman that you know is in a
relationship or could we perceive it as
oh she's single like you what I'm saying
how long ago do you break the
perspective thing um 3 years ago I would
I would have never get back with him oh
this is 3 years ago yeah but he he he
would always come back I thought you
said you were come back I thought wait
wait I thought you said you was you were
18 he was 28 mhm but so how aren't you
26 yeah so then you would have been 23
is this a different ex yeah so this is a
different ex yeah okay so I've been with
him for like four
years 23 I was so so when you were you
were 22 you got with him for 4 years no
18 I got with him okay no no the last X
how long were you with him Portugal X
this no this was the main serious
relationship I would consider in my life
the rest was like getting to know you
maybe going get
married I just need to direct like okay
how old were you when you met him how
old were you when you madam when did you
break up 18 we had an on and off
relationship up until 22 23 I would say2
okay so 20 18 to 22 that answer your
question
no wait so 8 18 to 22 so you dated him
for 4 years on and off so on and off
that means the relationship was [__] but
the sex was good no no then
why why is on and off no we've never had
sex okay okay someone else asked the
question someone ask question actually
I'm a blank right now four years of this
wow that's I are you a
virgin
yes do we have stop the C
button cat button there's no C button
here hold on you're you're you're you're
what what I don't know okay no
disrespect we shouldn't even have this
discussion why about me right now now to
be fair for me yeah I'm just learning it
cuz this is a completely different
Insight because cuz you're coming with a
Muslim background yeah and you got these
types of insights behind you yeah this
sounds pretty different to me like for
example youve saying like you're 26
right now you're virgin we're in a
western Society I haven't heard that
since I was like 15 that someone's a
virgin this so that's the re why like
we're asking and it's like this is the
thing as well it's they surprised
because you don't portray yourself like
a
virgin which is which is a which is a
great you know based on you're are you
BN are you I'm not I'm not saying it's
like a well a born again they don't they
don't believe you but I'm saying there's
a reason they think you're capping don't
be stupid yeah there's a re there's a
reason they think you're capping no okay
you think I'm capping for my Instagram
but no one has virgin on their no but
I'm saying no yeah but usually like I've
had virgin girls come on the show where
nobody really nobody really like wait
wait nobody really like pushes back
right but it's not like it's just it's a
good thing right that's like a great
thing I think that's awesome but it's
like it's like unfortunate cuz I'm like
No One Believes you because of the
Instagram like so you might it's like
it's it's like it loses like that's a
great thing nobody has that that's why I
want to change my Instagram too I should
probably all kind I'm going to go home
and I'll C that
picture I have to okay I'm just going to
give you the chance right now hen do you
remember the conversation we had before
the cameras were on what do you mean
what conversation did we have about the
situation you told me about I don't
remember we we were just talking in
general no but do you remember about the
situation you told me about that I was
giving you advice on it was a general
situation I can't remember exactly word
for word but what does that have to do
with this podcast because you just told
everyone here something that from that
situation I was that what what were you
talking about cuz I wasn't talking about
me and myself in that situation you you
were I don't want to out you cuz I know
maybe you don't want to you don't want
people to know I don't know what you're
talking about honestly I was talking
about situation with my friend just in
general but I don't know what I I just
met you do I know you look don't be rude
to me yeah because I'm I'm not trying to
be rude don't be rud to me I'm just
you're like trying to say some sort of
say I haven't I haven't hold on I've not
said anything about anything yeah I'm
just saying do you remember the
conversation that we had I remember some
of the conversations we had yeah most of
them yeah she's like a politician isn't
it yeah
so I'm just I did not have sexual
relations with that woman how long ago
was this conversation this was about an
hour ago so you you remember all of it
then don't you yeah yeah I remember okay
you now you're saying I remember some of
I remember the conversation we was
talking about a lot of things yeah okay
but no but we specifically were talking
about a situation that I was giving you
advice on we were talking about for
about 45 minutes right he was talking
about about a certain that was my
situation that was your situation no it
wasn't stop the
cap you know stop the cap I don't know
why you don't get involved with you're
you're literally saying cap this cap
that you don't know me come can don't
come here with your fake suit and your
fake teeth and okay wait before notary
but listen but can I say this though can
I say this I like that you're not going
to insult him going to go you're not
that's fine but he's saying I'm capping
and all this but
myself read the label it's lur you don't
have to get defensive you don't have
it's about me and myself and my if
you're just going to AR like can I say
this then I was making a joke about the
fresh and fit podcast when they push the
button it goes be stop the cap that that
is actually a thing on the fresh thing I
thought you was trying to trigger me I
apologize if that was the case but you
could come check the label on my suit
it's it costs more than your outfit okay
that's can I say this though real quick
hey guys guys guys guys let me just
before he woman that's okay cool cool
but let me say this you know the reason
why I feel there could just be a bit of
tension right now and a bit of
disagreement is only because earlier on
when you were speaking about the city um
girl situation or the the holiday thing
that happened I remember at one point
you did also say oh and then that happen
and it's not me saying that you liar or
anything like that it's just that within
this limited time of knowing you yeah if
I if someone says a story then misses
out a story I can only go off my
imagination in it it doesn't necessarily
mean that I'm tying you or saying yo
straight hole straight this it's not
that but you have to remember all of us
not all of us but all a lot of us are
just meeting each other for the first
time and we're going off of you see
first impressions are the most important
because they're the ones that stick the
longest so obviously in regards to the
Instagram it's not even like I've looked
at the Instagram and said yo your dress
mad it's not even that it's just that
when you say I'm a virgin and then
there's quite a few westernized
similarities like just in commmon
similarities like do you see how someone
a stranger could be like oh maybe I
don't 100% know if she's a virgin not
yeah that's fine but that's you lost
opinion you lost that's fine everyone
can have different
opinion you can't insult my guest I
apologize for him cuz I thought he was
coming for me and to calling me a liar
that's why and that was to do with me
personally I'm not here to disrespect
anyone but I just felt a bit attacked so
I was defending myself he wasn't he
wasn't attacking you I just F cuz when
he I know you I know you felt but it's
like you keep having this like visceral
Rea you can stay because you apologize
okay mhm if if you want to you can say
but but you can't you can't you can't
insult my guest like that's it's not but
you would you were deflecting as well
because it seemed like there was some
opposing evidence to what you're saying
it wasn't it was just everyone just
putting their little two cents in and um
it wasn't you guys don't know it wasn't
facts as well so it was just a bit like
I'm saying what I'm saying you should
just respect what I'm saying whether you
believe it or not and just call it a day
that's it but to some degree though like
it's it like to some degree I accept
that that's fair it's just that to some
degree though it is a it's a public
podcast that we're all just putting
opinions forward is it like it's normal
that someone can put an opinion forward
yeah and if I think yo boom I don't
really agree with that or I don't I
could be wrong you know but it's it's
for you to be able to be like you know
what yeah you may not be agreeing with
me but this is a podcast is it but it's
like but people are just going to have
something to say against what you got
say of course that's that's why I'm on
social media I already know that people
are going to say this and that about me
so it's okay it's cool where's my best
actor award yeah cuz I need to hand out
over real quick
thisy
SM come on now don't don't be doing the
back and forth thing with a woman stop
fishing for an argument please don't
tell him what to do he's fishing for an
argument you're the one arguing with
everybody why is he saying talking about
I'm going to pass my War to come on man
you're just trying to I say so I just am
confused you guys had a conversation
before the show we had a conversation
before the okay I'm going to I'm going
to ask him questions and I'll ask you
questions so so this convers this
conversation yeah a't my show so so this
conversation you don't have to tell me
what she said but it's basically
contradicting what she's saying now yes
no no I'm asking him no no no I'm asking
him I'm asking man there are some things
that she has said on this podcast right
that does not align with things she that
we discussed but it's her life I will
not disclose anything that she said
because we were discussing I was helping
through a situation so I wouldn't
disclose anything because if she doesn't
want it to be public that's fine but
that's why I was asking her do you
remember the conversation because it
doesn't some things are not aligning you
know this happen to me that's respectful
I wasn't even talking about myself in
that situation okay I've warned you I
told you I told you I'm going to ask you
questions in a second okay go no I need
you this is I've warned you you got to
go all right that's fine I'll just go
cuz this is just feeling a bit like too
much of a attack for no reason okay I I
come here for okay okay that's fine just
go it's fine I'll
go Troy all come sit next to you
please I need a hug
now uh I know that's what they're saying
they're like why' you bring it up it's
like what did she okay uh we're g to get
into the you know you you know what's
funny though I'm not I'm I'm anything do
you know what's funny though this
happens to me all the time on the show
this happens to me all the time we're
like someone will say something but I
don't want to say anything yeah I can
yeah yeah I I I saw it in real time no
no and it's like yeah so I I know what
you mean I think ultimately like you
know go ahead ultimately like people
should like [__] it I think some people
been new in it oh mine no no that one
like
this but yeah if you're coming on the
podcast you should know what you're
saying look listen like Everyone's
entitled to their privacy Etc that but
I'm bit like oh boy if you've said
something I don't know like if you said
something that I'm like I was just
that's why I said look I'm just saying
do you remember the conversation we had
does the does the truth trigger people